the ferry to Elba takes an hour time
enough to look forward to the beautiful
beaches in crystal-clear water when you
stroll through elvas capital port afar
yo you'll find plenty to remind you that
the islands most famous resident was
Napoleon Bonaparte Napoleon lived in
exile in the villa de maleeni for ten
months in 1814 and 1815 a group of local
history enthusiasts liked to dress up in
Napoleonic era costumes for special
occasions
they're proud that the former french
emperor chose this island for his exile
as ruler of the tiny principality
Napoleon had 10,000 subjects and an army
of 1000 men
increase the poky means in the few
months that he was here Napoleon managed
to give the capital city port of Rio an
administrative structure to unite the
island is this little my he turned port
of Rio into a miniature Paris eg the
port of Rio and he also introduced court
life here
Aquarion de una Corda intimacy in 1815
Napoleon returned to France and tried to
re-establish himself that ended at
Waterloo
today most visitors to the island are
vacationers Elva has large beaches but
also many small coves accessible only by
boat or long hikes
the island has about 200 beaches no two
of them alike if you're lucky you might
find one just for yourself I arrived
after a long hike you have the feeling
of having truly accomplished something
like climbing a mountain peak but of
course it's very nice in a canoe or on a
ship guys if you're looking for a
comfortable but nonetheless thrilling
way to reach the top of El Vez highest
mountain take the cable car in marciana
in the northwest of the island in just
20 minutes it will take you to the peak
of monte copani
at 1019 meters it's the highest point on
Elba here there's a view over the entire
27 kilometer long island you can see the
Italian mainland the Turanian coast with
Piombino the town closest to Elba that's
where the ferry set off for Porto for IO
they continue on from here to the island
of Capri there you can see Corsica on a
clear day ekwa or vista llamó la Corsica
Mariana marina a perfumer in the harbour
town has made it his goal to capture the
scent of the island with the perfume
aqua de alba several shops here sell it
as a souvenir
tourists like the idea that they're
taking a bit of the sea back home with
them and that's not just because of its
color for our scent we use only plants
from the Mediterranean region like curry
plant Arbutus also known as madrone
strawberry tree rosemary lavender and
many other indigenous plants perfunctory
what then we should prefer modal Mari
when we want to add the scent of the sea
there is the sea daffodil and seaweed
and then of course the sea breeze that
transports delicate salty sense
transport delicata Nautilus alley
the town of capo livery on the south of
the island is great for an evening
stroll
Luciano Cassini has operated his
restaurant here for more than 40 years
he specializes in fish and seafood
hardly surprising on an island
everything here is traditional my menu
is straightforward mostly I baked fish
in the oven or barbecue it and that's
what people like coming up with water
lotion after the heat of a summer day
the cooler evening hours are a pleasure
on Elba and you can count on the sun
shining again and again throughout the
high season in July and August